the bus surrounding Victor wimpinyama
for this year's NBA lottery is on par
with the likes of LeBron James Zion
Williams him or shot the seven foot five
Frenchman is a skill the Prospectors
we've ever seen with the Smooth release
three-point range ball handling and shot
blocking ability wimby is no doubt a
Transcendent talent but just how big is
the hype and expectation around him
compared to other generational talents
in recent years LeBron James was
featured on a Sports Illustrated cover
at age 17 and participated in the first
nationally televised regular season high
school basketball game on ESPN since
1989. the 18 year old entered the league
under what felt like insurmountable
pressure as he drew comparisons to
grades such as Magic Johnson and Michael
Jordan his teammate Anthony Davis was
deemed a generational talent and one of
the most dominant college players ever
coming out of Kentucky receiving
comparisons to Bill Russell Kevin
Garnett and others Zion Williamson was a
social media phenomenon who had everyone
thirsty for his next highlight at his
size and with that skill set and
explosiveness you've never seen a
prospect like him Luka doncic was an
international star before he stepped
foot on American soil he was a child
prodigy and started as the greatest
European Prospect the NBA has seen when
Victor win benyama has in common with
all of them is he's been stamped as the
prize of this year's draft and whether
he's the most hyped Prospect of all time
or not he'll be doing things on the
court that we've never seen anyone do
for years to come